hey guys I want to show you something
that is really really cool this is a
live camera right now we should have a
live bug on that uh this is either
Shadow or Jackie it's a Bald Eagles Nest
that the live pick is 24 7. it's in Big
Bear Valley okay and this is a pair of
nesting bald eagles mated bald eagles
and that's the friends of Big Bear
Valley have been following for several
years now they made all year long they
nest in the same tree and they put this
camera up this is either Jackie or
Shadow I don't know which one but they
have been protecting the eggs that are
in this nest and it was so snowy and
windy yesterday this poor eagle has not
moved off its eggs for at least 24 hours
to protect those eggs and the Big Bear
got seven inches nine inches of snow
yesterday they're looking for four feet
of snow over the next several days I
don't know how these Eagles do it but
they're so protective they will not
leave their eggs you know so they take
turns of course watching their babies
but friends of Big Bear Valley uh
they're a non-profit they protect and
preserve the natural ecosystem and the
surroundings and the wildlife and they
try to teach people about all the
beautiful Wildlife there in Big Bear